prior to trump it I started around 2013
2014 I started to get really
disillusioned with the state of our
politics and seeing that the current
options and the current system really
was not serving people and as someone
who got into it motivated really to
serve and motivated to small D you know
democratize politics to give people a
greater voice in the process I started
to get more reforminded and Trump really
accelerated that
[Music]
thank you
it's my pleasure to Welcome to the
podcast an awesome Civic entrepreneur uh
and former vice presidential candidate
that's right she was Evan mcmullen's
running mate in 2016 and she's been
doing good before and since Mindy Finn
welcome Mindy thank you so much Andrew
it's great to be here and see you again
yeah great to see you as well we saw
each other last in DC at one of those
save democracy conferences uh has
democracy been saved yet I guess not uh
so you and I are still in the thick of
it uh so right now you're the CEO of
Citizen data which you started a number
of years ago you guys just came out with
a fascinating new report uh what is
citizen data yeah so citizen data is a
data and
research company we're actually a
company but all for social impact that
was really responding to the need for
better non-partisan data in the
political sphere and policy and cultural
sphere that can truly help us to to
bridge divides you know the the major
Investments and plays politically just
like it's been in kind of all parts of
our ecosystem when it comes to data have
been for Republicans to win Or democrats
to win or you know to win very hot
button ideological Republican policy
fights or Democratic fights and so we
just thought there was a real
opportunity for an infrastructure that
could serve what we kind of anticipated
would be a growing need for data and
analytics that can can Bridge divides
and and turn A New Path forward well you
were prescient and on the spot in
building exactly what we all need but
you got into this work a bit before then
can you trace your career path a little
bit you worked in Tech and then uh wound
up uh in the intersection of Tech and
politics how the heck did you start
heading down this path yeah no it's um
I've been
um a little bit of a unicorn
unfortunately not your classic Tech
unicorn you know that gets mixed to
billions of dollars in a company but um
but from a political perspective in that
I I really I started actually my career
as a journalist very early on
um just had this interest did have an
interest in politics and
um and service and and covering politics
and just happened to have an internship
my senior year where I was assigned a
right for a newspaper uh in Connecticut
and my first day on the job was 9 11.
um and yeah talk about getting thrown
right into the deep end so suddenly like
the reason a student 20 year old like me
had an opportunity to write and cover
Washington is at the time no one really
cared that much what was happening in
Washington back when we had newspapers
those stories were back of a section or
b-section stuff but suddenly I was
covering 911.
um but also as part of those internships
I kind of um again this the internet
obviously was on the rise in journalism
but it wasn't taken seriously enough
that serious journalists were really
paid to do it or there was any budget
dedicated so I had a lot of opportunity
um to kind of write and cover my own
stories and my own topics I did that for
CQ which has now kind of folded into
roll call
um and and also for kind of local
newspapers and taught myself how to code
and and how to do Photoshop and the
basics things that you would need
because I would had to be a one a one
woman so to speak so um after 9 11
College I I decided I didn't want to be
a journalist because I did have opinions
and I wanted to actually be on the front
lines and making a difference and I made
my way to Capitol Hill and because of
those skills that I had I just kind of
often was the person that was given the
job to also you know do the website and
and I was recruited to the Bush campaign
in 2004 to this very new thing called
they all called it an e-campaign which
is kind of a funny name these days to
think about but it was essentially the
early days of digital politics
um and got what I call kind of a tenure
education in one year as part of a very
small department on the Forefront of
digital politics for the the bush
re-elect and it led to a nearer kind of
decade plus career
um as a as a digital kind of a techie a
digital entrepreneur within the
political system
um into time at Twitter and working for
Google and whatever
um but really prior to trump it I
started around 2013 2014 I started to
get really dissolute visioned with the
state of our politics and seeing that
the current options and the current
system really was not serving people and
as someone who got into it motivated
really to serve and motivated to small D
you know democratize politics to give
people a greater voice in the process I
started to get more reforminded and
Trump really accelerated that well heck
I mean you you did the craziest thing
possible which you joined up with Evan
McMullen in his presidential campaign in
2016 which I saw as a very very Noble
effort uh it might have uh swung a state
like Utah where I think Evan got 20
percent or so and I joke sometimes Mindy
that I appreciate all the people who
worked on my presidential campaign
because it was such an objectively
unwise career move
that you know people aren't exactly
going uh into a campaign like that like
that thinking I'm going to wind up on
Capitol Hill
um straight after this campaign so how
long had you known Evan and how did you
get involved with that campaign so
directly so so I certainly did not plan
to run for vice president in 2016 or
maybe ever
um
well said no I'm like I was just gonna
wait a cycle or two before yeah I mean
there was someone an old friend kind of
in digital politics
um Adam Connor remarked at the time like
I've long said that for the digital
leaders on campaign should start to
become more campaign managers and Senior
staff but Mindy's left even further
ahead and in his running for vice
president but I had been an early leader
in the never Trump movement Kind of a
Funny piece of lore is that I'm
sometimes credited with starting the
hashtag never Trump well done and yeah a
few of us founded a pack that was called
hashtag never Trump and raised some
money to try it was too late too little
too late but we did have some success in
Ohio and other states but you know he
was already catapulting to the
nomination at that point
um and you know as part of that was
hooked up with this effort that was
trying to get ballot access for uh kind
of a last-ditch Hail Mary you know
independent run and had been working on
recruiting people like uh Colin Powell
or General Mattis or Connie rice or
something when Evan's campaign folks
reached out and asked if I would I would
meet with him to First just advise on
strategy and that kind of thing and they
arranged a phone call with me and him a
meeting actually and they said just to
be just to prepare you I think he's
going to ask you to play Jill Stein in
debate prep uh because there might be
the CNN debate among third party
candidates so I thought hmm okay like
that's why me but you know I guess I'm a
petite Jewish woman and I've been around
campaigns a lot done some debate prep so
it could be kind of fun and whatever
I'll take the phone call so there was a
grilling on this phone call about my
policy positions about my character
about you know a number of things that I
thought was all a pretty cursor and he
told me he was likely to ask me
something at the end of the call I
thought that question was going to be
will you play Jill Stein and debate prep
Instead at the end of that conversation
the question was would you consider
being I need to find a running mate and
would you consider being my running mate
I that was a surprise
um and I didn't have much time to really
decide
um and so the time I actually had I
think my kids were like two and three
again as I said I had business things
going on
um I talked to my husband but also what
you said struck a chord which is I did
reach out to some friends and said
you know very confidentially what do you
think and their first reaction was well
you do realize this could kill your
career like so have you thought about
that you know it's like if you want to
do it you should do it I understand why
you might be morally motivated to do it
but it could be a career killer
um and I I went in knowing that that may
be the case and
um I wouldn't say it was a career killer
but it certainly closed a lot of doors
in the path that I had been on before
this podcast is sponsored by Helix sleep
what the heck is Helix sleep it is the
mattress of the future company I have
always been someone who valued my sleep
figured you know you're gonna do it for
seven maybe even eight hours you wake up
feeling refreshed and energized what is
that worth Helix sleep can help make
that happen just take their sleep quiz
and figure out what personalized
mattress should be shipped straight to
your door and you have a hundred days to
return it I don't recommend returning it
after 99 days but hey who am I to say
don't take my word for it it's the
number one rated mattress from GQ and
wired can you imagine being the mattress
tester it's a job someone has it Helix
is offering 20 off all mattress orders
and two free pillows for our listeners
right now go to helixsleep.com yang this
is their best offer yet and it won't
last long with Helix better sleep start
Starts Now
foreign
well in terms of closing a lot of doors
you mean within the Republican Party
you'd worked with a lot of Republican
campaigns and the Republican party right
now is facing a resurgent trump
candidacy a lot of people feel like uh
it's 2016 all over again what do you
think the greatest hopes are in terms of
not having Trump uh as the nominee again
in 24. so
I have been pretty
uh
consistent unwavering
um in not underestimating Donald Trump
from the beginning
um and I am still there I think we I
think as a country we have been late to
and we've underestimated the threat and
a lot of time not when I say we
obviously that's not everybody but
collectively there's more people that
have kind of underestimated the threat
and then came to understand it later but
we've also kind of underestimated you
know his political longevity and his his
political talent and appeal I mean he's
incredibly popular he's lost obviously
some popularity within the Republican
party from his Peak but he still has a
strong and extremely loyal base and he
still is able to benefit from a politics
of fear and grievance and victimhood and
so the the more that he is
um under attack that strengthens him
which we saw with the recent indictments
and so given all that kind of to get to
the the punch line on it
um I I mean I think he's the presumptive
nominee in the Republican Party
um today and I thought that a month ago
a year ago you know two years ago if he
decided to run again and from everything
that I've analyzed I don't unfortunately
see that changing and um I talked to a
lot of other political prognosticators
even in Battleground States and I I do
think you know there's a little bit of
um I understand it you got you got to be
hopeful or you don't get into politics
right you got you got to believe in the
impossible and go for it but
um kind of crafting out these various
scenarios for others to get to the
nomination that you know I'll go for it
like I I'm all for them I think everyone
they should try and
um Trump should have competition and
Challenge and and face you know a real
serious competition but
um right now you know he's he's the
presumptive front-runner and and most
likely nominee so aside from Ron
DeSantis who do you think uh is the
greatest challenge to Trump either data
driven or you know from your your gut
shooting from the hip I'll just throw
out I feel like Tim Scott has like a
really good energy and profile and has a
high ceiling and I hear really good
things about them from people that know
him
um so that that's one of my dark horses
like uh do you have him or another yeah
right so
off-road for for anyone um
somebody who actually can differentiate
themselves from Trump
um not somebody who's been a never
Trumper that's not going to work in the
party but uh but someone who who has a
unique
um who operated in a unique Lane which
DeSantis problem is he doesn't entirely
do that obviously people like my pens
don't do that Nikki Haley has struggled
to do that many of the other candidates
struggle to do that I think someone like
Tim Scott could potentially do that
um Issa Hutchinson is someone I would
like to see also be successful because
he has been a successful governor of a
you know ruby red State
um and actually was able to to bridge
divides and and get some really
practical things done
um amid again a very ideologically
conservative State
um he I think managed covet much better
than than others so he has uh we saw how
he operated in a crisis I think it's a
tough road for these folks but it would
be a Tim Scott or an ASA Hutchinson um
if a you know a new nuran that would be
you know somebody who I certainly would
be rooting for as well
so you decide to say yes to Evan uh even
though you know you I guess you
understood there could be some profound
ramifications and Trump was very much uh
in control or about to be in control of
the party at that time
um what were your experiences like on
the trail uh were you concerned about
frankly threats to your physical safety
um what what was campaigning with Evan
like yeah so many ways first of all I
would say it was
overall a just a incredible experience
and really transformative in my life so
I would do it 10 times over even though
it was only for a couple of months
um I like to say I got some of it's many
ways the best ways of running for you
know on a presidential ticket in that it
was short-lived one didn't have to do it
for two years four years we didn't have
to spend that much time raising money
because we just didn't raise much money
and it was too late and we didn't have
you know years of Oppo flying at us we
did have some Oppo and and I'll get to
the safety point in a minute and I got
to run like really run with a partner
like we both were first-time candidates
um kind of having to figure it out as as
we went and and then I think the thing
that was kind of the
um theme around our our campaign was
just that we were wanting we were giving
voters an affirmative and a positive
pro-democracy option at a time when
voters were very dissatisfied
um with the two options they saw both
these candidates as corrupt it was very
much as it has tended to be there was a
hold your nose effect where you would
hear a lot from voters that they were
having to go to the thinking about going
to the polls and having to hold their
nose for one of those candidates Hillary
Clinton or Donald Trump whereas our
supporters would come and say thank you
like thank you so much for giving me an
affirmative option that we can go to the
polls and vote for and be really proud
walk out with our head held high that we
voted for for you with your positive
message with your bridge building
message with your pro-democracy message
you know your anti-corrupt and
Corruption message and Beyond
um and so I just found it incredibly
inspiring especially when students would
say you know this is my first time
casting a vote and I kind of didn't
imagine this you know these the way the
presidential cycle had shaped up I
couldn't have imagined that and now I
get to vote for you or you know veterans
who had said something similar just in
the states we campaigned in which we're
limited but just Utah is where we ended
up spending the most time at the end you
just saw like real
um retail kind of local politics was
it's just a ton of self-organizing
people organizing their own events for
us you know setting them up at their
town hall to make sure they had an
opportunity to hear from that from us
and
um it really felt like the best of
America on the other hand we did
especially once we started to catch you
know at least a bit of fire in Utah and
appear to be a threat there
um the Trump campaign in particular sent
um hecklers and detractors to our events
who would cause a lot of problems
um and be yelling and screaming there
were threats to our safety there were
cryptic letters that were sent to my
home while I was traveling you know
where my husband young children were at
the time that you know we had to you
know turn into the FBI we ended up
having to get security at the end uh we
couldn't qualify we didn't qualify for
Secret Service it was kind of too late
anyway so we had to hire our own private
security
um so it was
um you know sometimes when I reflect
back there was moving so quickly that I
couldn't even fully appreciate at the
moment
um the type of risk that we may have
been facing but it certainly was
certainly there and it certainly reminds
me now of the types of risks obviously
all people in public life face but a lot
of the election
officials who who had to stand up
particularly against their own party for
the legitimacy of the the 20 2011
results it's gotten darker since even
that cycle
um though thank you for your service and
your courage uh and uh congratulations
on giving people something positive to
vote for so again you did get I want to
say about 20 of the vote in Utah which
is a freaking ton I mean if you think
about it yeah so in Utah we got it was
like a little over 21 I mean at one
point yeah at one point we were actually
pulling ahead or even with the other
candidates Trump actually he didn't come
to Utah but he sent a pence there and
Pence's big message it was very clear
and it was really powerful it was really
about two things one was the Supreme
Court and kind of like you need to vote
for Republican to get our judges on the
Supreme Court and also just come home
like come home to the Republican party
you know this is home to you which is
really pretty interesting you know we
think about politics as really serves
this role in people's lives of this
place where they belong is their
identity and Pence stepped into that for
the campaign he told people come home
and and that really was effective you
know for those Republicans um but we
still yeah we got over 21 of the vote in
in Idaho we got 12
um I I believe
um you know we weren't not all these
ballots were counted everywhere because
they don't count them unless they're
going to make a difference on the
outcome but we got the highest number of
presidential write-in votes sort of at
any cycle ever you know up to that point
um so I'm very I'm very very
um proud of what we were able to do
um on a shoestring budget you know the
dollar per vote couldn't be beat um in
terms of the amount spent versus
um you know what we did and more
importantly it was the message we were
able to get across and and form the
foundation for a new movement in
politics which continues today and
um you know you've really taken the
mantle and are running with it's awesome
that you frankly managed to like get
their attention to the point where they
had to divert uh Pence to head to Utah
because the last thing anyone thought
was going to happen is they had to spend
time in Utah
you guys did great yeah it was really
funny actually because Trump started to
talk about our campaign not even at his
rallies as we know he's a little bit
sensitive you might say and so he didn't
like the fact that there was any kind of
challenge
um and so he's like there's this guy by
McMullen who's you know campaigning
going coffee shop to coffee shop in Utah
which is like pretty funny because
notoriously you know Utah is a heavily
they don't really drink so much stuff
don't drink much coffee yeah so it shows
how much he knew about it
thank you
three quarters of Americans wish they
started investing earlier and over
two-thirds of Jen's ears feel the same
way you know why it's tough It's because
it's tricky it's daunting it's
intimidating you know who started an app
to solve that are the founders of Bloom
Bloom app is the award-winning Financial
Services app it's made by young people
for young people I've met the founders
they are great guys who want to make you
or the people in your life who are young
and just starting out financially
literate check it out at bloomapp.com
and there's a special offer for
listeners to this podcast 15 in free
stock and one month subscription for
free go to bloomapp.com Yang to sign up
today bloomapp.com Yang why stay in the
dark in terms of financial literacy
let's get educated people bluemap.com
yang
[Music]
foreign
so you transitioned from there to just
trying to movement build
um you know along with Evan stand up
Republic which became a new America
which now merged with a forward party
um so some of your former colleagues are
now colleagues of mine including folks
like Miles Taylor and then you uh
simultaneously I think also started
working on uh what became citizen data
so what was the evaluation process like
after the McMullen campaign you guys sit
together and be like okay guys now that
was great we got all of these uh you
know tens maybe even hundreds of
thousands of votes uh they're all these
people want want what we put out there
into the marketplace
um so let's build on this yeah that's
right you know I think Evan and I
um sat down and I you know I didn't make
this clear earlier we really we didn't
know each other before we ran we had a
lot of mutual contacts and Friends uh
but we didn't know each other so we met
through the campaign but really formed a
good
you know professional partnership we're
extremely aligned in the way that we saw
the problems in the country and what we
thought needed to happen moving forward
and I think when we it was pretty
quickly we just really felt a
responsibility
um to continue the momentum forward
um maybe able to relate to this from
your experiences running where you know
you have these supporters who are
they're they're so behind you and they
put all this effort in and we obviously
had a very Grassroots volunteer driven
campaign
um and even though you know Trump won
that well especially because Trump won
that election
um they're hungry for a place to to
connect and continue to continue to
build on that momentum and and to fix
our politics and and then I think the
other thing that we really were
concerned about is we started to learn
about the existing uh kind of
infrastructure I should say of
non-profits and advocacy organizations
that were focused on Democracy
strengthening is that there was a real
risk the Trump selection that the whole
cause of democracy would just become
even more of a partisan cause and being
like only the Democrats would be
associated with democracy and I think
that's a that's a really big problem for
the country that we felt we needed to
solve for and so our whole kind of
theory of change you know the problem
that we were seeking to solve for was
yes to do Grassroots movement building
but also to ensure that the fight for
democracy which was going to strengthen
post-trump we knew it would
um would become a cross-partisan or
non-partisan cause and not only be kind
of centered and held within the the
Democratic party well heck a lot of the
folks who've joined forward resemble
people like you and Evan where you would
have classified yourselves as let's call
it moderate Republicans uh 10 years ago
and and then now the Republican party
has shifted into something else and to
me it's one of the great problems is
that you have in my opinion millions of
uh principled page patriotic Americans
who right now are like well I'm not in
love with what's going on in my party
that's called the Republican party but
you know certainly can vote for anything
with a d next to it so like what are you
gonna do you know and so the hope is
that you can say well what you could do
is join a group that actually is
positive and stands for values and it's
not all about trying to defeat uh that
the other side uh all the time and um
and so you did that with Evan
um with both the campaign and what
became a new America we're trying to do
that with a forward party and I'm sure
there are all these people around you
who resemble that I was with Governor
Christy Todd Whitman uh last night the
co-chair of the forward party and she
clearly resembles that yeah I mean that
that's right and you know and you asked
about kind of the citizen data I think
what ultimately after a couple years or
so when Evan and I were building set up
Republic and really starting to
um to feel good that you know for I mean
tons of problems so there's a lot of
problems to solving democracy but more
people were starting to realize that
right like if there's still a lot more
growth that needs to happen but there
were more organizations more leaders
more funders more you know more people
pointed at the problem
um I I just what I started to feel was I
always kind of have this question like
what is the highest value that I kind of
personally can bring you know to the
country like what is the unique thing
that I can do at this moment and uh it
became clear that there was the need
there's a lot of infrastructure needs
but there was a data and research needed
for the nonpartisan data uh side of
things and that's what my specialty had
been within the Republican party I did a
number of things but the last thing I
did was oversee the data technology and
digital apparatus really for the entire
kind of RNC and so this is something
that you know I I can do I can I can
build this and it's going to be needed
and it's going to take you know time
obviously for a more independent
movement forward to to grow and the
ecosystem that you're tapped into but we
know this will be needed so you know
we'll start this and and get moving
um and it's been really I mean one thing
that I love about it I love a lot of
things but um is that we really get to
we you know we've obviously work with
you and the forward party as well as
other nodes within this ecosystem this
caress of kind of organizations and
leaders who you know don't agree
um on everything sometimes they don't
agree on many things policy wise and
have different experience but kind of
share this fundamental
um love for obviously America for
democracy and this agitating for for
change and a better path forward
um forward like I keep I keep like using
your brand just naturally you know it
just rolls off the tongue Mindy yeah
that that that's why it's there
foreign
this podcast is sponsored by expressvpn
in a tough economy you're looking for
ways to save money and you know a sneaky
way you can do it expressvpn now you're
asking yourself how is that possible
doesn't expressvpn cost money it does
cost less than seven dollars a month but
it can help you unlock content that will
save you money for days and days what do
I mean for example let's say I'm a Duran
Duran fan which I am I want to watch the
concert movie of Duran Duran but it is
not available on Netflix in the US
however with expressvpn I can just beam
myself into the UK click on Netflix and
voila
Duran Duran and a bunch of other content
I could not have gotten any other way
it's a no-brainer if you want to
preserve your own data from the big tech
companies and get more content and save
money while you're at it go to
expressvpn.com Yang don't forget to use
my link so you can get three extra
months free that's exp r e s s vpn.com
Yang
expressvpn.com Yang to learn more
foreign
you guys came up with a fascinating
report of many I'm sure I mean I'm sure
you're getting all sorts of uh data so
some of the takeaways from it were that
uh guess what turning off primary is
actually really helps reduce extremism
where you're three times less likely to
elect let's say an election denier or
something along those lines
um there's been a lot of data in the
Press recently from Gallup polls and
other sources about the proportion of
Americans who now identify as
Independence rising up to uh 49 or 50
percent
um so you are someone who is on top of
the data
unlike just about anyone else what did
you get out of the latest report or
really any of the your recent findings
yeah
I know you track really closely to which
is the willingness to vote for uh a
third party or a different party than a
democrat or republican candidate and
that number has kind of continued to
grow I mean we have a majority of likely
voters who are at least somewhat willing
to to vote for a third party candidate
if they say so
um which is you know obviously an
important number to track
um I think the other thing that was
really critical and the research that we
did pre-election 2020 in post-election
is that there's kind of this
conventional wisdom among politicals
politicos and even among researchers
that democracy is just not an issue that
voters really care about at all you know
they could care about kitchen
quote-unquote kitchen table issues and
and democracy just doesn't matter
um and what we found that that that's
actually changing so yeah it was not the
number one issue
um you know by by any means the number
one issue for voters tended to be
inflation across the board
um you know Republicans some of them
it's immigration and safety and for
Democrats abortion was a big one this
year but democracy was ranking and
protecting elections in particular was
ranked right up there three or four
particularly in Battleground States
um where voters really understand kind
of the way that the system of democracy
the strength of our democracy truly does
matter uh and I thought that was one of
the the more interesting things that
really kind of cuts against this idea
that democracy doesn't matter and in
fact among voters that there weren't for
you know at that point there weren't
forward party options um but there were
an expanded number of we call shifters
or split ticket voters
um who would vote for you know a
Democrat for for one Statewide office
and a republican for another Statewide
office there were more of those in
Battleground States this year and for
those voters in particular protecting
elections Fair elections
um ranked higher
um you know than kind of your mean voter
which really indicates that for them it
it may have been a voting issue even if
it's not the issue that it's not the
same as making sure they have enough
money in their pocket it's it's pretty
close
um so those are some of the things I
think the other thing that we do a lot
of work on
and we tracked in this recent report is
just the the uh energy behind reforming
the primary system and giving voters you
know more options yeah most voters want
it they voted yeah it's really popular I
mean the only thing that's more popular
you know than that when in kind of the
realm of Reform is just money and
politics I mean voters who do that as
really the biggest problem
um and that's the harder one it's and
you know I've you know been on panels
about that
um there's things you can do but it's
it's a harder not to crack but democracy
reform really has a lot of momentum and
in each individual state that we've
looked at it as well across the country
uh both Republicans and Democrats uh
really want it they want it they want
better representation better options
more voice more Choice yeah almost 60
percent of Americans want to get rid of
uh party primaries so that's a great
sign for let's say Nevada uh next year
and what percentage of Americans say
they're at least open to voting uh for a
third party 60 percent
about the same sixty percent uh you know
obviously
um that's a lot higher than you need in
theory you don't even need 51 you know
you might need 35
um I'd actually tell people the real
number uh of what you would need to get
on board something like the forward
party in Earnest is only really more
like 10 because in a polarized country
you could swing a lot of races and do a
lot of good with that kind of Base yeah
that's right and you know
um I think the thing to look at too is
younger voters so the trends um younger
voters hate the parties yeah so younger
voters are most likely to identify as
independent be most dissatisfied with
the two-party system the most supportive
of a reform
um even you know youngest the youngest
Republicans
um there's a like a major Delta between
support for democracy reform among
younger Republicans and older
Republicans
um which I think is a really strong you
know Omen and gives us a really good
foundation to build on for the future
wow Mindy talking to you is so fun and
encouraging you've got so much good data
uh so let's say someone listening to
this is like a relatively ordinary
person how can they keep up with you or
even support the work that you're doing
yeah they well they can go to our
website citizendata.com
um you know I would say to definitely we
have a number of reports that you can
download and take a look at you can
schedule conversations to talk to our
team if you're an organization that
would benefit from data we can serve you
we're not we're interestingly we're not
fundraising right now in the way that a
non-profit does we've raised some rounds
of funding in the past we may do that
again so if there's someone out there
who's really interested in that feel
free to to get in touch with me at Mindy
at citizindata.com but otherwise please
do check out our website and in
particular I'd say download that
political impact report because that
gives you a lot of the Nuggets that you
need to really build this new way in
American politics and to truly
understand uh what's what's happening
and what the potential is for change
there's so much good data in there it's
incredible
um I'm going to close with a question
about AI
um so you're much more tech savvy than
the average uh political actor or
journalist that's for sure like what
what do you think about the arrival of
AI in in this election cycle yeah I
think it's really
um well from my perspective it's really
exciting I mean I have concern turns
that you know many share about some of
the ethical issues and and the ways that
it will be utilized and just how you
know how fast it's moving is both
exciting and scary and and I get that
and we can hold that those two truths at
the same time
um but I'm really excited about it um
from the perspective of
um really just understanding the
American public and being able to be
responsive to their needs at scale
um you know and I I actually think that
I'm not too concerned about the
political ecosystem moving too fast
because the political ecosystem is just
notoriously slow
um you know there's a lot of kind of
speculation for example that AI will
just absolutely replace things like
survey research which our team does a
lot of
um and I don't I don't actually think
that will happen so fast just because
political political people are just
naturally slower to embrace change but
you know we're certainly using it we've
already been using a lot of
sophisticated tools for natural language
processing even of survey results
um you know of online conversation for
example to understand what people care
about what they're talking about to make
sense and bring greater insight to the
kind of American psyche
um and political it if you will so I um
I'm really excited about it from that
perspective and and certainly you know
my team of of data scientists and and
political number crunchers are are
having a field day with the increased
openness to AI new AI tools um and we
are you know stay tuned working on some
fun things
um to to be able to very quickly make
best use of them as we head into the
2024 election cycle well that's a more
positive view on it um than a lot of
other folks have and we'll take it Mindy
Finn CEO of Citizen data most
importantly uh true American Patriot
leader uh so excited to be working
alongside you in this space and who
knows maybe you'll wind up on another
ticket at some point another ballot
likewise Andrew we'll see we'll see
[Laughter]
we'll see thanks so much Mindy and
really congrats on everything likewise
talk to you soon
foreign